oh
testing out the Apple watch Ultra on the
extremes
the water fountain
yeah
after using the Apple watch Ultra for
some time we have some questions and
some of these questions might be the
same questions you have if you do have
them let us know in the comment section
below we're also going to get a
triathlete to really take this watch
through its Paces but this is a really
good watch and a watch like this is
gonna bring up a lot of discussion some
we may agree with and some we may not
and some we hopefully Apple will watch
this video and go hey we didn't think of
that or hey we actually have an answer
for that and we can find out because
this watch is going to open up the doors
to a whole new Marketplace for a lot of
you out there in the Apple ecosystem
that you've never had before in this
particular way first and foremost let's
talk about this Apple watch Ultra this
will be the watch I think a lot of you
out there will be aiming to get you
might not be a triathlete you might not
be an Iron Man athlete you might not
hype to Mount Everest it doesn't matter
most people who buy a Rolex Submariner
or a Panerai submersible like myself
don't do deep sea diving we get these
watches because we love the design and
let's be honest over the past 8
iterations of the Apple watch they all
look the same they might have gone a
little bit larger but really nobody
knows what series Apple watch you wear
with the ultra
now they know
when you wear the ultra
it signifies that your air is serious
or you could be you're a person who
takes help seriously you're looking to
push yourself you're going to stand out
in the crowd
and some people just want to flex that
way let's be honest but
we're going to talk about some of the
features that I think a lot of you out
there who do use the watch for these
type of things are going to really
appreciate okay case in point for me
personally I own two Garmin watches the
Phoenix 5 and a Garmin Mark watch and
I'm used to the Garmin interface I use
it for cycling as well and Garmin makes
fantastic sports watches and fantastic
monitoring devices but they're not the
most user friendly when it comes to
finding things in the menu the sub menus
the graphics they can be a little bit
slow a little bit inundated and they can
be very frustrating to use sometimes you
need a degree to figure out how to use
the products
apple is taking their very friendly UI
they have developed over eight years of
the Apple watch
I said we can enter this Marketplace we
can make it a lot easier to give you the
information you need and they do it
brilliantly
as a matter of fact when we had a
meeting with our triathlete he was
shocked at how all the features that
would take him
15-20 minutes to figure out on this
Garmin watch were readily available for
him within seconds but I'm sure for a
lot of you out there who are going to be
using the watch to that extreme we'll
also find out that this watch is very
easy to use but that also does leave us
with some questions first off now
physical buttons which are great
do the physical buttons work as
described so first we have the action
button which is an orange color which
you can assign to any functionality that
you wanted to do is going to be a
workout it could be a stopwatch could be
whatever you want it to be then you have
another button on the side next to the
digital crown so these buttons are great
to use and I appreciate them and I
applaud Apple for doing this because I
am tired of swiping on my watch I cycle
a lot my hands get sweaty I don't want
to take my hands off the bars I'm
cycling and swiping through my watch to
see information I know I shouldn't be
doing that I should do it at the
stoplight but sometimes I need to see it
and I want to just press a button and go
to where I need to go and this watch
allows me to do that which I greatly
appreciate it but the way the buttons
are designed you're naturally going to
gravitate to pinching both buttons at
the same time will that cause a problem
later on down the road for athletes will
they have to be remind themselves just
press on the left side for the action
button and don't press on that right to
hold that the watch on my wrist it's
gonna be interesting you might not think
of these small things but these are
things that do come up when you use the
watch over time they make it very
interesting another thing I like the
digital Crown it's a little bit larger
easier to use with gloves so as a
cyclist who uses gloves when I ride even
a motorcyclist for that matter I can now
access the digital Crown without
worrying about it the size of the watch
is very important a lot of you out there
going is this watch really that big 49
millimeters so I want this side of this
large size of a watch and look I wear a
patternized submersible 44 millimeters I
wear a Rolex gmt2 it's around 40 to 42
millimeters this watch feels really good
on the wrist it's very lightweight
thanks to the uh Aerospace Titanium on
it it feels really really nice and the
straps are absolutely awesome but they
are not cheap 100 US dollars per straps
so invest wisely pick the right color
and the right material I would say for a
lot of you out there that want that
larger display because you're going to
get six rows of information versus Five
On series eight this will come in handy
even if you want to read an email it's
easier to read on this watch versus a
series 8. well let's talk about some of
the other things in this watch you have
new GPS system you have an L1 GPS and L5
GPS very similar to what on polar and on
Garmin on the higher end watches but
it's reliant on the Apple Maps only now
depending on what part of the world
you're at Apple Maps may be fantastic or
maybe subpar you do not have a choice to
use another map system so if you use
Google Maps or whatever Maps you want to
use you can't you're reliant on Apple
Maps only now in the future they're
going to be having a diving application
which you can go deep sea diving they'll
be working with a third party vendor for
that because Apple doesn't do deep sea
diving so you'll be able to use this as
a dive computer which is fantastic we're
not going to test that right now because
we don't have the app on it but we're
going to go more into the uh the Iron
Man kind of workout cycling running
swimming with our triathlete we'll let
you know how that goes but I think
there's also some other questions that
we have now crash detection same as
series 8 but why was crash detection
only tested for car crashes what about
motorcycles what about cyclists for that
matter they say well you have fall
detection
okay
but wouldn't crash detection be more
viable for motorcyclist who gets flown
off the bike versus somebody in a car
with multiple airbags who's kind of
enclosed and is probably relatively safe
I don't know it's a question I have also
temperature readout now we know that
they talk about temperature readings in
terms of ovulation Cycles now I don't
have an ovulation cycle it doesn't work
for me what I would love to have because
over the past two years all I've been
doing is taking my temperature
everywhere I go because of covet I would
love to have a watch that tells me my
body temperature if I'm not feeling so
well that as you see the temperature
raising that alerts me hey your
temperature is raising a little bit if
you want to get checked out we know this
is not going to be a medical device but
we have the ECG readings on this we have
the heart monitor readings on this we
have all these things that will alert us
when our heart rate goes up it'd be nice
to have this for our temperature at
least let me know if I want to check my
body temperature for whatever reason I
can check it it may not be 100 accurate
I get it but it would be nice to have
and of course for the women out there
who do have an ovulation cycle
Apple's gonna help you get pregnant
they're going to let you know when it's
time to
when it's time not to
I mean that's great Apple helping us
make babies in Singapore we need the
population get outside of that Guys
these are some of the questions I have
on the Apple watch Ultra we're going to
take it through its Paces I love the
design I love the look of this thing and
I'll tell you what if even if you don't
want an orange strap or whatever these
kind of these more like rugged straps
you can use your standard Apple straps
dress it up it will look badass we've
seen it with the leather strap it's
awesome so with that guys subscribe to
the channel if you like this video and
if you want to see more of our reviews
check them out right here